uh look at the end of the day uh
i think i've been more nervous
for this pog champs than any other pog
champs i don't know why even my poops
have been weird today and i think it's
because i've been nervous i we didn't
the game is sort by the way it is a um it is
it is a scotch opening so ludwig correctly
plays i believe little is white right yeah so
he correctly plays bishop to e3 does not play
c3 like xqc did against uh moist critical in the
previous match where he played with c3 queen f6
knight takes c6 queen takes f2 checkmate uh lotus
plays bishop to e3 which i think he is prepared
well it looks like i was not oh logic blunders
on oh no yeah and as i was saying that our
screen sharing software caught up uh we've
got a blunder oh man this is bad oh yikes
and this is i think the big danger i think um
is the opening phase when i've seen several of
these players like um logic and xqc in particular
i feel like both of them are very talented players
once they get out of the opening phase of the
game but in the opening phase if they get into
trouble they can end up too far behind to come
back and i think so far very unfortunate start
for uh for logic and i think ludwig should win
this game he's up a juicer already he's got two
bishops tonight against the bishop tonight
smooth sailing if he takes care of business
i'm just drawing arrows one of my arrows has been
played okay i'm not do you like this move i mean
i just simplifying as long as he stabilizes like
rook v8 could be annoying you know there's tactics
rook b2 yeah i love c5 i think for ludwig it's
great to trade now it's a critical moment probably
the last critical moment i would say the game
where logic can maybe come back because if uh
if ludwig is able to develop the bishop and castle
the king or move the queen and castle the king and
avoid getting into trouble here he should win the
game that's a solid move but let's see if it works
i just think that this threat although met with
this is results in a pretty fierce group here
which i don't know if necessarily is that
bad for me if i'm castling kingside but
i think normally in games especially around
my level the b2 g2 b7 g7 pawns are oftentimes
captured by the queen and that can be make or
break for either side for the capturer or the
uh the defender and why enter a situation like
that when i can just play a normal developing move
perfect spot on yeah and again i mean it's it's
obviously winning for white with correct play but
it's still if you're ludwig you're a little bit
concerned because i think ludwig really wants to
castle uh kingside and i think he's probably
a little bit nervous to push the f pawn here
yeah exactly f3 is probably one of the best moves
he might also play bishop back to e2 that would be
a great move also yeah bishop e2 just trades the
bishop i th the worry is that he plays queen d2
okay plays f3 f3 is good yeah it's also good yeah
queen d2 would have been bad because of bishop f3
and now i have a bad feeling logic is okay okay
that's a good move bishop is a great move now
the question here is will ludwig see the castle
queen side and he does actually see it which is
which is important so it goes queen e3 i think if
ludwig can get his king castle as the king side
he's very likely going to win this match that's
what i would say perhaps worth putting my king b2
soft very soft move wise but since there's no dark
squared bishop it's pretty sound yes not the worst
idea ever but you are in the face of the pins so
and like right now this is like kind of like it's
like when i watch like better people play chess
where we are just improving our position but we
have no real actual breaks happening until
just then yeah that huh i just wish though
because if okay so takes takes takes man
he's so lucky queen a1 is not just made right
sure i don't think i'm missing anything oh
man well he might see it now right before
he does it if we just pull this up like
whoa bishop f5 is a really sneaky move
yeah wow that's a very sneaky move by um by
logic look at that he he notices the change
in the position and he he's man i would love it if
black had these b and d rooks that would be oh man
oh no oh no oh my god it's pond no way
pontics pond come on logic take the juicer
no way logic might be playing this in a tricky way
like he's maintaining the pressure on d5 but he
if he takes knight d5 he'll spot queen a1 it shook
me yeah you just got to go just take the pawn yeah
he did have it in his plans to play king b2 i
don't know if logic ended up seeing that queen a1
keep saying both of their names for
the other person i don't think ludwig
saw that after knight d5 there was queen
a1 but uh oh he hung me oh oh no oh my god
he hugged me
oh he's a god oh he hasn't
he had no idea he's a god
what a god that is heartbreaking
oh my god no i mean it wasn't it
wasn't a godly move i mean he just he
maintained the tension there ludwig
he carl ludwig had tunnel vision on the night
move so he just did it but he didn't oh my gosh
crazy oh that is heartbreaking yeah
because you know how much prep went
into the opening there ludwig's ludwig
prepared that opening he got everything
he wanted he got the trick he got the
piece and then he just hung queen a1 man
crazy absolutely crazy oh that
is absolutely heartbreaking
but did you see the the life vanish
from my face on to game two just as hard
ludwig by the way has played uh
the queen d6 scandinavian so if
anybody wants a very easy opening to to
play get get that scandinavian and uh
play this so someone's done some videos on i feel
like someone oh wait but you you recommended queen
a5 right levy no i i i talk a little bit about
everything but thank you for plugging me yeah
that's uh great great see we're like volleyball
you know but but will he play a6 okay he clearly
has done his breath isn't this exactly his game
against charlie was this exact opening but i think
charlie went bishop e2 and so he didn't go b5 but
in this case logic did put the bishop on c4 so he
did play b5 which is very good yes it looks kind
of scary like i i mean it looks like the queen
is just like it's it's really near your bishop
i think and it just it looks scary optically
so oh no oh look oh my gosh logic just logic
just gambits a bishop to start this game too
oh wow okay yo what is this guys guys is this does
does logic think he can think he's bobby fischer
or something he can spot his opponent an extra
bishop every game that maybe i mean if ludwig's
gotta win now i i i oh come on come on what's he
saying i want to hear this i'm up an entire piece
you go for it man you do you i feel
you bro but i'm just gonna go d8 man
annoying stuff because yeah i mean logic is
playing not to lose cons considering he won
the first game so one and a half oh he's going
for the big cheese the big cheese now if ludwig
plays queen f6 here queens are coming off the
board and there will be no excuse for him to
not win the game yeah he he sees it one move
he sees it and he's trying to play f6 ooh ooh
yeah he is you just push don't push don't just
push push don't push push but if i push what
changes in the position well my king is no longer
protected so he goes check nice he saw it yeah
perfect great everybody benefits he yells a lot
he can take and then win the bit of the rook
so that's not the best move there you
go in fact how about we just make this
really obvious about what i want to have
happen good just play clean out six yeah
oh he said queen here oh oh oh there it is yeah
that's the the way that he worked protect that
i don't really good cheeky checks
the way that he worked that out
out um not to do the pun but the way that
he worked out the sequence was perfect
literally perfect the way that he worked out the
sequence perfect queen f6 and absolutely perfect
that was uh that was super very clean yeah and if
ludwig doesn't win here i mean he doesn't deserve
to you know to win the match i mean because this
one he's he's definitely got it he's got it going
here queens have to come off the board he's gonna
be way ahead by at least one piece so i mean this
is this is it for ludwig he's got he's got to uh
he's got he's got to get it done yeah for logic to
now come out of this without losing any material
he probably has to like take the queen and then
take on c6 right right and it's too limited just
too limited so i i think ludwig is gonna win here
really i mean the thought process there was
absolutely brilliant by ludwig the way that
he worked out f6 is the queen h5 queen e7 then
realizing why don't i make it really simple and
really obvious and now logic just hangs a
second juicer in the middle of the board
yeah queen takes knight and um and then ludwig is
going to coast to victory but i still still feel
like it's very easy to sort of lose your mind
and panic after that first game which is like
what happened like and you just kind of want to
move really fast but one was being very slow very
methodical and he's really working it through yeah
like exactly he said f6 and a lot of us just go
f6 oh that looks pretty good but never in the
history of chess haven't you ever thrown plus six
well but surely i could find
out a way to make it happen
oh man uh it's like it's like those basketball
teams you know uh let it be a lesson no one ever
beats us by more than 30 you know by 29. so uh
no he's got a point he deserves he deserves both
games frankly but he wandered that first one yeah
real i i think ludwig realizes that he's ahead by
a bishop and a knight so it doesn't matter
you just want to make sure queens and rooks
come off the board if you can if you're gonna
offer the trade so queen five is the best move
and logic either has to trade queens or play
queen d3 or queen e2 and neither of those moves
are gonna get the job done so right yeah i
think it's very likely we're gonna have uh
we're gonna have a have a five minute game for
all the marbles and ludwig gets white because
okay yeah knight g5 okay now just swap
and that's all she wrote that's game over
yeah please don't go rook t8 oh my god
please don't go rook t8 that would be insane
and now you can laterally swing it to d7
or e7 what a move yes rook d8 rushing with
the trade would have resulted in rook e8 you
lose a knight and then you're paralyzed yeah
that would have been that would have been
a serious throw so rook a7 is a great move
yeah also rookie 7 is kind of a rook lift again
remember in his match against moist critical he
missed a rook lift so it's kind of like and
rick actually rookie seven is the best move
white can't sit white's gonna have to trade us out
straight off rooks here and then white's left with
one rook and and ludwig should win this pretty
cleanly yes very nice conversion from him yeah
it's never or i mean actually it is true though
if you don't see f5 it is kind of tricky to play
here like king c2 now you got to go kingston
too then work d2 checking you can use the other
pony to make the chucks but okay now knight c3
and rook d1 it's an arabian checkmate knight
three and it's the the arabian mate here does he i
mean he also can go rook d1 and then knight c3 so
yeah he but the thing is if he's not confident
after that first game he's gonna think he messed
up and now he's gonna go panic mode and play
like knight takes f2 which is still winning
right but ludwig's been very composed here he
seems very composed and very measured so i don't
think he's just gonna panic here uh now if he had
like 30 seconds i could see it but not with three
minutes on the clock um i kind of think rook d1
is the move he should be able to spot here right
because it's just like you know what they're gonna
do they're gonna take and then knight c3 but so he
had almost dr he almost played knight g2 check and
i found it nice wow dude nice move by by ludwig
very nice move yeah and that's it it's mate
yep sick suck me very nice game bye bye
strictly better strictly better
there's nothing else to say
go ahead no i was to say we got a scotch and i
was just okay uh did did logic prepare something
because yeah he did he improves i i was sure
he had an improvement i don't like this line
improvement line though necessarily i still
would have played bishop b6 yes to guards i don't
i thought the idea of bishop b6 and knight f6 is
even if it's not correct at the grand master level
it's a simple free-flowing plan playing queen r6
is much more double-edged that being said look at
ludwig he's deep in the tank if white doesn't
know what to do it can be very dangerous for
white as well i love queen a4 by lovely even if
it's not the best move i love it it's aggressive
oh no no no no although i'm not taking with the
pawn there oh he might play king b8 dude he might
play king b8 ju oh my gosh queen a7 tunneling
he's just tunneling the whole queen side oh man oh
now he's gotta really just okay b6 queen
eight is made and oh c6 this should be six
that's actually i don't hate that move man i
don't hate that move and if black can get the
knife to f4 he has all kinds of threats with
checkmates yeah that rook is guarded and it's
getting closer on time it's about 10 seconds
now okay we went a lot uh we went to ludwig
he hung his knife oh no rook takes knight oh no
oh my gosh that's insane wait let's
let's just bring that back um oh
rook takes knight and now queen
f2 queen g2 is just game over
like yeah and oh and he's
queen of two oh no oh no oh no
logic misses it queen of two oh no the
only one oh we missed it and now he's
and then queen c8 and there's actually a staircase
checkmate oh man logic through maybe seven's mate
mate rookie 27 27 there's three mates here
for white oh my gosh oh what a huge throw
let's go the question is lovely realized that
he was meeting and [ __ ] that's actually the
big question victory it's a swing to realize
that it was meeting two is the question that's
actually what i'm curious about i was scared for
a moment there was some f2 action oh he he sees it
yeah it doesn't matter what this chat's
going to definitely tell him now for sure
i just want you to tell me uh to tell tell
everybody what you told me man because your
mentality through all this you know people people
in a game like that would be stressed angry
your mentality is very different so i mean i'm
going home to a fine ass woman and a baby so
i'm happy i mean and at the end of the day this is
for charity this is my first time and i i wouldn't
want to easy win like it was very you know he
played really great and yeah there's nerves that
come with it when you have thousands and thousands
of people watching you it's not like performing
that's easy that's what i do like i say like i'm
a rapper i'm not a chess player professionally
even though i love the game so there's things that
i miss there's things that i still don't see and
i don't necessarily see it as a negative you know
because people could be [ __ ] boys about it and
try to be like oh you lost or you this you that's
like no i won i made money for a charity and i'm
happy but i did take a l to my man's bloodwork
today so i will wholeheartedly admit that um
but you know missing things like like in this
in this last game with the with the mate in two
um it just gets me more excited to further learn
the language of chess and have the vision for it
so at the end of the day it's like we had
fun um you know it's all going to charity
and hopefully you guys will let me come back
because i'm about to be i'm gonna be on it now
ludwig congrats man now you gotta you gotta top
that off man how do you feel how'd you bounce
back is two matches now where you you you
start with the with the 01 what do you do to
what do you do to get hyped up motivated to to win
it after taking a loss in the first game i think
logic is is uh i mean a hell of a public speaker
but everything he says is uh is resoundingly true
that like i got checkmated on on a1 and i will
that will never happen to me again and so the
biggest takeaway is uh i've improved my game
of chess so that's i can uh i can i can take
that away but i felt good after i got a dm from
hess my best friend magnus we were chatting a bit
about like you know thank you uh yeah where
finland is on the map um but i i felt fine
because um because i was winning in the
opening and i think that was where i cause
i don't know dude logic is crazy man it's like
no matter what i did he always had an attack
and it was terrifying that i was up six in
game two and i was second guessing everything
i was doing because of game one in part but it
doesn't matter how many pieces i'm up by he just
always has an attack in mind and uh and if you
don't know how to deal with it it's terrifying
i also think sometimes like i'm so focused on that
attack or looking for a check that i leave a piece
hanging you know yeah second game i really did
mess up with that bishop and i should have just
brought it back for sure but i don't know why it's
like saw that square i was like i'll be fine here
and your night ticket is hilarious yeah it was
an early lead and that made it feel better but um
i mean hats off to you because it did not feel
good um one getting stomps game one and then
game three was terrible i felt terrible the
whole time i started just a nod in my stomach
i think that's a very very good mentality well
we got we got ludwig you're you're going into
the semi-final yeah um you know there's been a
lot made of the the different players involved
in the semi-final there's it's a lot of players
you yourself i heard you on a stream one say you
thought you might be the worst player in the
champions bracket i don't want you to think
that way we got logic here he's hyping it all up
you're you're in a semi-final with rayne wilson
and benji fishy saying it out loud doesn't
change the fact i yes exactly what you said
i am in a semi-final with benji fishy a 16 year
old cracked genius sardoche like a 1500 man
and then rayne wilson i am not sitting pretty
in this tournament but uh look at the end of the
day uh i think i've been more nervous for
this pog champs than any other pog champs
i don't know why even my poops have been weird
today and i think it's because i've been nervous
i uh we didn't all right well i'm just letting you
know that this is what pogchamps is doing to me
it's sucking my soul away levy okay all i can do
is go out there and play the best chess i can and
if that's enough hell yeah and if it's
not then shame but that's all i got